(singing) ... (screams loudly)
(suspenseful music)
(lightheart jazz music)
- Not today, Playboy. Not today.
(screams loudly)
Hello, 911. Yes, I have an emergency.
There is an aggressive spider
that refuses to leave my home.
Did I mention that the spider
was on top of a burglar?
How could we not have
any Raid in this house?
A bug not gonna stop me from
watching TV. This is my house.
(TV plays in background)
I already seen this
episode of Maury anyway!
Does PAM cooking spray kill spiders?
Look, Fam, if you leave
right now, just out the door,
I promise to never kill
any of your homies again.
Bees, flies, ants, other
arachnid ...things.
Please leave.
I'm not yelling. I'm not yelling.
If a spider comes into your home, okay...
And they say, "Hey I'm a spider.
I don't care if I didn't get an invite.
This is where I want to be."
What are you gonna do? What
are you gonna do? Do your job!
Not today.
(chuckles) Got you, sucker.
Houdini bug!
(suspenseful music)
The game has changed.
(soft jazz music)
- What are you doing?
- I don't wanna talk about it.
- Whatever. Where'd you
get the briefcase from?
Goddamn that. C'mon, we gotta go.
Did you see the size of that thing?
Bitch, you ain't just out
just here. - I know, I know.
- We've gotta go. - I know.
- Ride in the back.
- I've got matches.
- [Man] Burn it down. C'mon,
burn it down. Let's go.